las primeras 117 mil dosis de la
iniciativa kóvacs en américa aterrizaron
en colombia con el objetivo de acelerar
el proceso de vacunación en el país una
apuesta solidaria que a veces ha sido
puesta en entredicho muchas personas en
el mundo dudaron en la efectividad de
esta de esta herramienta
pero hoy queda corroborado no solamente
que kóvacs está activo que funciona sino
que empieza también esta distribución en
distintas latitudes del mundo américa
latina es una de las regiones que más
espera que esta iniciativa multilateral
sea efectiva entre marzo y junio la
región tiene previsto recibir más del 10
por ciento de las dosis distribuidas a
nivel global es decir 35 6 millones los
primeros países en beneficiarse serán
además de colombia perú el salvador y
bolivia que a través del programa piloto
nombrado primera ola recibirán 375 mil
dosis de facer bayón tec en las próximas
semanas precisamente estas cuatro
naciones están entre las más lentas en
el proceso de vacunación en la región
ni siquiera han puesto una dosis al 1%
de su población
algo que contrasta con otros estados
como brasil o chile
kóvacs se articula como una opción
imprescindible para países que no han
tenido la oportunidad de realizar
grandes acuerdos bilaterales con las
farmacéuticas y pretende apostar por un
reparto justo frente a la acaparación de
vacunas